Hurricanes, wildfires and floods. School shootings, the pandemic, a youth mental health crisis, inflation and rising interest rates, the war in Ukraine. Some days it seems like all the news is bad. And some days it seems that this media stream of death, doom, and destruction is unavoidable. Are you suffering from news overload? Do you find yourself doom scrolling when you should be sleeping, eating, playing with your kids, or doing your job?
飓风、野火和洪水。校园枪击案、大流行、青年心理健康危机、通货膨胀以及不断上涨的利率、乌克兰战争。有时候，新闻似乎全都是坏消息。有时，这种充斥着死亡、厄运和毁灭的媒体流似乎让人无法避开。你是否也正饱受新闻过载之苦？你是否发现自己本该睡觉、吃饭、陪孩子玩耍或工作的时候，却在无休止地刷着负面新闻？
Do you feel hounded by algorithms that keep sending you more bad news not only to your social news feed, but to your email as well? Why is it so hard to shut off the news spigot even when it's only making you feel stressed, depressed, and anxious? Is there anything you can do to control this constant barrage of news yet still be informed? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that explores the connections between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills.
你是否觉得各种算法如影随形，不仅把源源不断的坏消息推送到你的社交新闻动态中，还发到你的电子邮箱里？为什么即使新闻只会让你感到压力、沮丧和焦虑，想要关掉这个“新闻水龙头”也这么难？对于这股源源不断的新闻轰炸，除了照单全收，难道就真的无计可施了吗？欢迎收听《心理学说话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）的旗舰播客节目，主要探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是主持人金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。
I have two guests today to talk about news media overload. Dr. Marcus Brower is Professor of Psychology at the University of Wisconsin-Madison, where he directs the Brower Group Lab. Research in his laboratory focuses on group and intergroup processes, including the consequences of belonging to high and low-power groups, and how belonging to in-groups and out-groups affects people. Dr. Brower is also a co-author of a 2021 study that found consuming news about the COVID-19 pandemic was associated with emotional distress, which we will talk about today. Our second guest is Dr. Don Grant, a media psychologist, researcher, and an addictions counselor with expertise in technology's
今天我请来了两位嘉宾，和大家聊聊新闻媒体过载的话题。马库斯·布劳尔（Marcus Brower）博士是威斯康星大学麦迪逊分校的心理学教授，并在该校领导布劳尔实验室（Brower Group Lab）。他实验室的研究重点是群体和群际进程，包括属于高权力或低权力群体的后果，以及属于内群体和外群体如何影响人们。布劳尔博士还是2021年一项研究的共同作者，该研究发现，消费关于新冠肺炎大流行的新闻与情绪困扰有关，我们今天将对此进行讨论。我们的第二位嘉宾是唐·格兰特（Don Grant）博士，他是一名媒体心理学家、研究员兼成瘾咨询师，在科技对心理健康的
impact on mental health. He is president of APA's Division 46, the Society for Media Psychology and technology. He is also the national advisor of healthy device management for Newport Healthcare. His research includes investigations into the potential effects of media exposure, social media, cyberbullying, and device-driven attachment bonds on adolescents, teens, and young adults, and our culture at large. Welcome to both of you. Thank you so much, Kim. Thanks for having us. As I said just a moment ago, it feels like we're drowning in news, much of it disturbing, if not downright bad. Is it just my gut saying that there's so much news today that there's much, much more than
影响方面拥有专业知识。他是美国心理学会第46分会（即媒体心理学与技术学会）的主席。他还是纽波特医疗保健公司（Newport Healthcare）健康设备管理的国家顾问。他的研究包括调查媒体曝光、社交媒体、网络欺凌以及设备驱动的依恋纽带对青少年、年轻人和整个文化潜在影响。欢迎二位。非常感谢你，金。很高兴来到这里。正如我刚才所说，我们似乎正淹没在新闻的海洋中，其中大部分令人不安，甚至可以说是糟糕透顶。难道这只是我的直觉吗？现在的资讯确实有这么多，比
there was, say, 10 years ago? Dr. Grant, as a media psychologist, what are your thoughts on this? Certainly, I don't know that there's any more information or news happening. The difference, in my opinion, is how it's delivered because maybe dating myself, but back when I was growing up, we had a television, a radio, and newspapers. Now we have the Internet, and we've got increasingly more platforms. all clamoring to get our attention with sensationalized headlines, again, in my opinion, on the same topic.
比如10年前要多得多吗？格兰特博士，作为一名媒体心理学家，您对此有何看法？当然，我不知道是不是真的有更多资讯或新闻在发生。在我看来，区别在于它们的传递方式。也许这暴露了我的年龄，但在我成长的时候，我们只有电视、收音机和报纸。现在我们有了互联网，而且平台越来越多。它们都在用耸人听闻的标题争夺我们的注意力，当然，这只是我个人的看法，而且报道的都是同一个话题。
My opinion is the inflection point happened in 2008. In 2008, Apple introduced the iPhone, which made the Internet portable. So once we had the news conduit or the information or whatever was, when the Internet went portable, in my opinion, that was when we crossed the event horizon. And now it is always, always available. and we have alerts and notifications and the constant checking. And I'm sure Dr. Barrow can speak about this more. But that's really, I don't think there's more news.
在我看来，转折点发生在2008年。2008年，苹果公司推出了iPhone，使互联网变得便携。所以，一旦我们有了新闻渠道、资讯或诸如此类的东西，当互联网变得便携时，在我看来，这就是我们跨越事件视界的时候。现在它总是、随时随地都触手可及。我们有各种提醒、通知，还有不停的查看。我相信布劳尔博士可以对此做更多说明。但实际上，我不认为新闻变多了。
I just think that we've got more accessibility to it. And we've got increasingly more platforms that are just all trying to get our attention to read about it. So let me ask them, what's the impact both psychological and physiological of exposure to so much news and so much of it being negative? Maybe news has always been negative, but it just feels even more so today. Dr. Brower, maybe you could talk about your study findings because I think you looked at some of this. I can. I don't think that it's just there's a impact of more news and that that impact is negative. The news themselves also have changed, right?
我只是认为我们接触它的渠道更多了。我们有了越来越多的平台，它们都在千方百计吸引我们的注意力去阅读。那么我想问二位，接触如此之多、且大部分是负面的新闻，会带来怎样的心理和生理影响？也许新闻一直都是负面的，但今天感觉似乎更加严重了。布劳尔博士，也许您可以谈谈您的研究发现，因为我觉得您研究过这方面的内容。可以的。我不认为仅仅是新闻变多了，而且这种影响是负面的。新闻本身也变了，对吧？
Dr. Grant just talked about sensationalism and how the greater competition leads actually to different types of news being reported. So it's not just more. It's also a different kind of information that is being communicated. And I think that's what has the detrimental effects. So let me talk about these detrimental effects. We did that study where we asked people about their news consumption, both on social media, television, and also newspapers. And where do they get their news from and how much time do they spend consulting in these different? So we're not. And then we also measured their emotional distress, self-reported emotional distress. And we found a positive correlation between news consumption and emotional distress.
格兰特博士刚才谈到了哗众取宠，以及更激烈的竞争实际上是如何导致不同类型的新闻被报道的。所以，不仅是数量变多，传播的信息种类也变了。我认为这才是产生负面影响的原因。那么，让我来谈谈这些负面影响。我们做过一项研究，询问人们获取新闻的渠道，包括社交媒体、电视以及报纸。他们从哪里获取新闻，花多少时间查阅这些不同的渠道？所以我们没有……然后我们还测量了他们的情绪困扰，即自我报告的情绪困扰。我们发现新闻消费与情绪困扰之间存在正相关。
It wasn't entirely surprising the social media we know with algorithms, those that get more click, have a little more negative news, and people report negative events more, they get shared more often. So all these algorithms sort of contribute to more negative news being shared. on social media. I have to admit that we were a little surprised by the positive relationship between emotional distress and newspaper consumptions. We somehow thought, especially in the early days of COVID-19, we thought that inform newspapers, facts, knowledge about infection, risk, what is, what do we know, what do we not know, what is true, what is not true,
这并不完全令人意外，我们知道社交媒体的算法会把那些点击量更多、带有更多负面新闻的内容推送出来，人们也更愿意报道负面事件，因为这些事件分享得更频繁。所以所有这些算法都在某种程度上助长了社交媒体上更多负面新闻的传播。我必须承认，我们对报纸消费与情绪困扰之间的正向关系感到有点惊讶。我们不知为何觉得，特别是在新冠疫情早期，我们认为提供事实、知识的报纸，即关于感染风险、我们已知什么、未知什么、什么是真、什么是假的信息，
we thought that that would actually reduce emotional distress. Well, we found exactly the opposite. It increased emotional distress. Do you have any idea why? I mean, I was going to ask at some point whether the medium matters, and it would seem to me that reading a newspaper, the imagery is more in your mind. I mean, there are some pictures, but you do have to imagine things as opposed to when you're watching TV or even seeing a video on the Internet.
我们原以为这实际上会减少情绪困扰。然而，我们发现的却恰恰相反。它增加了情绪困扰。你们知道为什么吗？我的意思是，我曾经想过媒介是否重要，在我看来，阅读报纸时，图像更多存在于你的脑海中。我的意思是，里面有一些图片，但你确实需要发挥想象力，这与你看电视甚至看互联网上的视频是不同的。
So what's the difference here? I think there are about five or ten causes that may be responsible for this difference. It's definitely the case that we found the strongest correlation between emotional distress and news consumption on social media. It's definitely true that the weakest correlation was between emotional distress and newspaper consumption. It was the weakest, but it was still positive and it was still statistically significant. The more somebody spent time reading newspaper articles related to COVID-19. the more emotionally distressed they felt. It is interesting to see this relationship,
那么，这里的区别在哪里呢？我想大概有五到十个原因可能导致这种差异。我们确实发现情绪困扰与社交媒体新闻消费之间的相关性最强。也确实发现情绪困扰与报纸消费之间的相关性最弱。它是最弱的，但它仍然是正相关的，并且在统计学上仍然是显著的。一个人花在阅读与新冠肺炎相关的报纸文章上的时间越多，
and we can only wonder what it is due to. I mean, once again, I actually think that even newspaper journalists are subject to that competition that Dr. Grant pointed out before. Nowadays, many of the newspapers, New York Times, have online versions, and here it's the number of clicks, and a journalist that writes articles that generates many clicks will have, their career will advance faster than that of a journalist whose articles have few clicks.
他们感到情绪上的困扰就越严重。看到这种关系很有趣，我们只能猜测这是由什么原因引起的。我的意思是，再次强调，我实际上认为即使是报纸记者也受到格兰特博士之前指出的那种竞争的影响。如今，许多报纸（如《纽约时报》）都有在线版本，在这里，决定因素是点击量，一个写出能产生大量点击量的文章的记者，其职业生涯的晋升速度会比那些文章点击量很少的记者更快。
So I think even journalists in news media are subject to the competition and the incentive structure is such to report more negative news and more sensational news. So then let me ask you, Dr. Grant, is some of the blame for this then lies at the feet of reporters or their editors and producers that they're just being goaded into basically producing more sensationalistic and even more negative news? I wouldn't use the word blame necessarily, but I want to take it back. We did a study, which was super interesting. We looked at one news story. We just picked one. And we looked at how news platforms around the world, because we wanted external validity, of course. So we looked at how they promoted and reported this one story,
所以我认为，即使是新闻媒体中的记者也面临着竞争，激励机制促使他们报道更多负面和耸人听闻的新闻。那么请问格兰特博士，这其中的部分责任是否在于记者、编辑或制片人，因为他们基本上是被逼着制作更多耸人听闻甚至更加负面的新闻？我未必会用“责怪”这个词，但我想回溯一下。我们做过一项非常有趣的研究。我们看了一则新闻报道。我们只挑了一则。我们观察了世界各地的新闻平台是如何推广和报道这则新闻的，当然是为了确保外部效度。所以我们观察了它们是如何宣传和报道这则故事的，
including the byline, the, you know, the title in the byline. It was fascinating to see the same story. And when you, when it came up in the feeds, how it was the, you know, because it used to be top of the fold, right, in newspapers and whoever had top of the fold and anyone's familiar with that term, it was whatever was on the front page. The front page now is one line, maybe six words, on an internet search or on a feed. So I also want to be fair, and I agree with everything, I think, where we're going. And we can talk about this more, and Dr. Broward obviously has the research. I have to look at that, Dr. Barrow.
包括署名、标题。看到同一个故事非常有趣。当它出现在信息流中时，它是如何被……因为过去报纸上有“版面头条”，懂这个词的人都知道，头条就是头版上的内容。而现在的头版只是一行字，可能在网络搜索或信息流中只有六个字。所以我也想保持客观，我同意我们讨论的方向。我们可以对此进行更多探讨，布劳尔博士显然有这方面的研究。我得看看那个，布劳尔博士。
That's really fascinating to me. You could see a story in a newspaper or on the news, which we trusted. Now, keeping in mind, there's controversy over the years about who controlled newspapers and media. But let's just remove that. that's a different podcast maybe. We trusted that what we saw was fact check. It was correct.
这对我来说真的很有趣。你可以在报纸或新闻上看到一个故事，这是我们曾经信任的。当然，多年来关于谁控制了报纸和媒体一直存在争议。但我们先不管这个。那可能是另一期播客的主题。我们相信我们所看到的是经过事实核查的。它是正确的。
I did an interview. I was very fortunate. I did an interview for a very prestigious newspaper on Monday, and they sent me fact checks later. But I also want to remind us that as we would maybe that morning read something in a newspaper or hear it on one of the news stations that we trusted, we go to the market and we're standing in line. and there are four or five different, they called them tabloids, maybe it had the same story,
我曾接受过一次采访。我很幸运。周一我接受了一家非常著名的报纸的采访，他们后来把事实核查发给了我。但我也想提醒大家，正如我们可能在那天早上阅读报纸或在我们信任的新闻台听到某些内容一样，我们去市场排队时，
but what we saw on the cover was a very different lensing of it. So it's not like I don't think it's new. I think that it's what Dr. Brower said and what I believe is that everyone, you know, is ambitious. We all want our careers to do well. And I don't know that they're purposely trying. but when you have increasingly more news platforms that are digitally delivered, all try to get your eyes on it and do, as Dr. Barber said, click on it.
会看到四五种不同的所谓小报，它们可能报道了同一个故事，但我们在封面看到的却是截然不同的视角。所以我不认为这是什么新鲜事。我认为，正如布劳尔博士所说，而且我也深信不疑，每个人都有雄心壮志，我们都希望自己的职业生涯发展顺利。我不认为他们是故意这么做的，但是当数码传递的新闻平台越来越多，所有平台都试图吸引你的眼球，正如布劳尔博士所说，让你去点击它时，
You are going to try to do something that is going to be alluring, attractive, and get them to click the same as I live in Los Angeles, and there's certain metropolitan areas that had back in the day two newspapers or more. So in certain urban areas, this is not, you know, a new practice where competing newspapers in the same market, I think probably had discussions about how to have people, you know, look at theirs of the same story. So I don't know that it's blaming. I just think that it's now. You know, we've got, they've got six words, maybe ellipses, ellipsies, when you look at a newsfeater, you Google something to grab your attention
你就会尝试去做一些诱人的、有吸引力的事情，让他们点击，就像我住在洛杉矶一样，有些大都市过去有两份或更多的报纸。所以在某些城市地区，这并不是什么新做法，在同一个市场中竞争的报纸，可能曾讨论过如何让人们阅读他们关于同一故事的报道。所以我不知道这是否应该怪他们。我只是觉得现在……你知道，当你看新闻流或者用谷歌搜索时，他们只有六个字，也许还有省略号，来吸引你的注意力，
and get you to click on that so you do. So the journalists get the clicks. It's also, and I just, I'll end with this, what Dr. Brewer said, also I think is a new phenomenon as all of these things are with digital, you know, things, this is all precedent setting. I think that before you were buying a newspaper, you were watching a news broadcast, which was inclusive of lots of stories. Now it's individualized and now you have the opportunity to really look at one story. So I don't think back in the day, I'm sure that letters to the editor or how reporters reviewed or how successful they were. I think there's probably a different metric, but Dr. Brower is 100% right. Now you're not clicking on necessarily the LA Times.
让你去点击它。这样记者就能得到点击量。这也是——我最后想说的是——布劳尔博士刚才提到的一点，我也认为这是一个新现象，正如所有与数字化相关的事物一样，这一切都是开创先例的。我认为以前你是买一份报纸，或者看一档包含许多故事的新闻广播。现在它是个性化的，你现在有机会真正专注于一个故事。所以我不认为在过去——我相信给编辑的信件、记者受到的评价或他们的成功与否——当时的衡量标准可能有所不同，但布劳尔博士是100%正确的。现在你不一定是在点击《洛杉矶时报》。
You're clicking on one story and that is a reporter. That is one. And we all know that the more clicks, the more likes, the more comments. That is the currency right now of success. Let me ask another question. I'm going to take us in a little bit of a different direction. Are there different reactions to all of this news based on age, gender, or demographic factors? Because my sense is that younger people might be less able to process and cope with a lot of negative news. You might think that older people are inured to it, right? We've seen it. But also, younger people are digital natives who grew up with social media,
你点的是一个故事，而那是某一个记者写的。那是其中一篇。我们都知道，点击量越多、点赞越多、评论越多，这就是目前成功的硬通货。让我问另一个问题。我想把话题稍微引向另一个方向。根据年龄、性别或人口统计因素，人们对所有这些新闻的反应会有所不同吗？因为我的直觉是，年轻人可能更无法处理和应对大量的负面新闻。你可能会认为老年人对此已经司空见惯了，对吧？我们都见识过。但另一方面，年轻人是伴随着社交媒体长大的数字原住民，
and they know this media firehose they've lived with their whole life. Baby boomers may be getting their news still from a physical newspaper, or watching the evening news. So are the physiological and the psychological reactions different, or do we even know at this point? I call this media saturation overload. And because I work with teens, and we all know the prefrontal cortex is not, they're overexposed and underdeveloped. They are not able to process and handle. And they also can sometimes be a little more emotional. But I just want to throw that in because I, what you just said that is I work with teens and listen to this every day. But Dr. Brewer, I'm sorry. I would love to hear your thoughts.
他们了解自己一生都在接触的这种媒体信息洪流。婴儿潮一代可能仍然通过实体报纸或观看晚间新闻来获取信息。那么，生理和心理反应会有所不同吗，还是说我们目前对此还一无所知？我称之为媒体饱和过载。因为我与青少年打交道，我们都知道他们的前额叶皮层尚未发育完全，他们过度曝光且发育不全。他们无法处理和应对。而且他们有时也会更容易情绪化。我只是想插一句，因为我……我刚才说的那些，我每天都在和青少年打交道，也每天都在听他们倾诉。但布劳尔博士，对不起。我很想听听您的看法。
No, you're entirely right. In our study, we did find a small effect of age. We found no effect of gender. We do find a main effect in the sense that younger individuals and female respondents reported higher emotional distress. And once again, I probably should say that was all during the initial weeks of COVID-19. We're not talking about June or July of 2020. We're talking here about March and April of 2020, when nobody knew what was going. on. There was a lot of, were a lot of uncertainties about how even the virus gets transmitted. Remember, we were, we, we used to disinfect our groceries with white, disinfectant wipes before we learned that it was airborne. Anyway, so that was that time, right? So we do find an effect, we find a small effect that that relationship between news consumption and emotional distress is
不，你完全说对了。在我们的研究中，我们确实发现了年龄的微小影响，但没有发现性别的显著影响。我们确实发现了一个主要影响，即年轻群体和女性受访者报告了更高的情绪困扰。再说一次，我可能应该指出，这一切都发生在新冠肺炎疫情刚爆发的最初几周。我们谈论的不是2020年的6月或7月。我们谈论的是2020年3月和4月，当时没有人知道正在发生什么。
stronger for younger individuals, as Dr. Grant predicted correctly. So, yes, it seems to be that younger individuals are particularly vulnerable to the negative impact of news consumption. And once again, think of our teenagers. Don't we want our teenagers to, like, read the newspaper, be informed of current events. So we, some of us may even encourage our teenagers to spend more time consuming news. well, by doing that, we may actually increase their emotional distress, at least in uncertain times like the initial weeks of COVID-19. So what's the answer then? I mean, should parents somehow control their children's news consumption? How can they do that?
有太多的不确定性，甚至连病毒是如何传播的都不清楚。还记得吗，我们以前会在用酒精湿巾擦拭杂货进行消毒之后，才知道它是通过空气传播的。无论如何，那就是当时的背景，对吧？所以我们确实发现了一种影响，我们发现了一个微小的影响，即正如格兰特博士正确预测的那样，新闻消费与情绪困扰之间的关系对年轻人来说更强烈。所以，是的，年轻人似乎对新闻消费的负面影响特别脆弱。再说一次，想想我们的青少年。难道我们不希望我们的青少年像阅读报纸、了解时事一样吗？因此，我们中的一些人甚至可能鼓励我们的青少年花更多时间消费新闻。好吧，通过这样做，我们实际上可能会增加他们的情绪困扰，至少在像新冠疫情初期那样充满不确定性的时期是这样的。那么答案是什么呢？我的意思是，父母是否应该在某种程度上控制孩子的看新闻行为？他们该怎么做？
I think not control, but maybe a company, and I'm sure Dr. Grant has many ideas about that, is be there and actually ask questions, help them sort out. relevant from ill-relevant information. And I want to bring up one point that's something that parents might mention too. We are as human being hardwired to direct our attention to negative events. That is very adaptive. If you have a bear at the side of the hiking trail, you want to react to that very fast. You don't want to have a two-second delay where you then maybe turn your head and see, oh, is that really a bear?
我认为不是控制，而是陪伴，我相信格兰特博士对此有很多想法，那就是陪伴在他们身边并提出问题，帮助他们把相关信息从不相关的信息中筛选出来。我想提出的一点也是父母可能会提及的。我们人类生来就习惯将注意力直接转向负面事件。这具有极高的适应意义。如果你在远足小径旁看到一熊，你会希望对它做出非常迅速的反应。你不会希望有两秒钟的延迟，然后才转过头去看，哦，那真的是一熊吗？
So we are hardwired to immediately direct our attention to negative events, threatening events, fearful events. We even react differently. Our amygdala reacts differently to fearful faces that we are exposed to. So if you now translate that to news information, we will be attracted. We will be interested, intrigued by information. that is negative. People, how many people are dying,
所以我们天生就会立即将注意力转向负面事件、威胁性事件、可怕的事件。我们的反应方式甚至不同。我们的杏仁核对我们接触到的恐惧面孔的反应是不同的。如果你把这一点转化为新闻资讯，我们就会被吸引。我们会对那些负面的信息感到兴趣、好奇。人们，有多少人死亡，
how many people get infected by COVID-19, how we can't do anything about them, how hopeless that all is, how terrible our world is, et cetera. So this might be something that parents could point out our natural tendency to consume information, to read information, to be intrigued by information that is negative.
多少人感染了新冠肺炎，我们对此无能为力，这一切是多么绝望，我们的世界是多么糟糕，等等。所以，父母可以指出这一点，指出我们消费信息的自然倾向、阅读信息的倾向、对负面信息感到好奇的倾向。
And then have teenagers help them think about how that attention then actually causes us to read more negative information, to click on articles that report something negative, and the detrimental effect that that might have on mental health. So I think parents, instead of prohibiting or not encouraging their children to consume news, I think they can help and help them interpret and identify what information is relevant and what information is useful, for instance, to reduce infection risk and to help them function in an environment, physical environment where a virus is spreading. And Dr. Grant, you said you work with young people and they're distressed by what they're seeing. How do you advise them? Well, and I also
然后让青少年帮助他们思考，这种注意力实际上是如何导致我们阅读更多负面信息、点击报道负面事物的文章的，以及这可能对心理健康产生的负面影响。因此，我认为父母与其禁止或不鼓励孩子消费新闻，不如去提供帮助，帮他们解读和识别哪些信息是相关的，哪些信息是有用的，例如降低感染风险、帮助他们在病毒传播的物理环境中正常生活。格兰特博士，您说过您与年轻人一起工作，他们对所看到的事情感到苦恼。您是如何建议他们的？嗯，我也
work with parents and what Dr. Brower was saying also during the pandemic, when we as adults and as practitioners, clinicians. We all were feeling it too, right? We didn't know. But I'm going to throw something out there that might be unpopular. What is more interesting to people? And then I'm going to frame it in a subset of teens, news or gossip? And when you hear a salacious little piece of something and you have social media where also now information, real or not, can be shared and shared and shared, but what are you really interested in? So I'm going to ask and call it back to that proposal I made earlier about even though we saw a news story, when we're standing at the checkout line and we saw some of those tabloids, I didn't necessarily buy them, but I certainly
与家长一起工作，正如布劳尔博士刚才所说，在大流行期间，当我们作为成年人、从业者、临床医生时，我们也都有同感，对吧？我们当时也不知道。但我接下来要抛出一个可能不太受欢迎的观点。什么对人们更有吸引力？然后我把它框定在一个青少年子群中：是新闻还是八卦？当你听到一些耸人听闻的小道消息，并且你有了社交媒体，在这里无论是真是假的信息都可以被无休止地分享时，你真正感兴趣的到底是什么？所以我要问这个问题，并回顾我之前提出的那个观点：尽管我们看到了一个新闻新闻，但当我们站在结账柜台前看到那些小报时，我不一定会买，但我肯定会
looked at it. And so that's also when you talk about real nose, when I talk to parents, we talk about fact versus fiction in general. So what Dr. Brer was talking about, I don't know that you know, if you tell a kid, would you rather read the, you know, the gray lady? Would you rather read something from the New York Times or what I hear less? Well, I saw on TikTok. So I don't think if you, even if a parent talks about legitimacy of news and vetted news sources and legitimate news sources, but when you have different platforms, what is a kid really going to be more interested in reading like the LA Times or searching
看一眼。所以，当谈到真实新闻时，当我与家长交谈时，我们通常会讨论事实与虚构的区别。所以，正如布劳尔博士所讨论的那样，我不知道……如果你告诉一个孩子，你愿意读那份“灰姑娘”报纸（指《纽约时报》）吗？你愿意读《纽约时报》上的内容，还是听我少听一点的……“哦，我在TikTok上看到了”。所以我不认为，即使家长谈论新闻的合法性、经过审查的新闻源和合法的新闻源，但是当你有不同的平台时，一个孩子真正会更有兴趣阅读《洛杉矶时报》，还是在TikTok上搜索、寻找、了解它？对他们来说，那是他们的资讯渠道。那才是合法的。所以我想提出这一点。而且，我很高兴这是一个播客。人们可能会觉得：“不，这不是真的”。但我跟青少年接触。我听他们倾诉他们从哪里获取新闻，从哪里获取信息。我有一个孩子告诉我，因为我也从事成瘾治疗，我有一个孩子告诉我，我错了，没关系。这是关于另一个话题的，但他告诉我，他读到大麻实际上对青少年的睡眠、使用和放松真的非常有益。我说：“哦，真的吗？你在哪看到的？”他说：“唐，在这件事上你弄错了。”我说：“好吧，你在哪看到的？”然后他给我看了那个网站。
for it or finding it or learning about it on TikTok, which to them is, you know, that's their news conduit. That's legitimate. So I just want to throw that out there. And again, I'm glad it's a podcast. People might have, no, that's not true. But I work with teens. I listen to them and where they get their news and where they have information. I had a kid who told me, because I also worked with addiction. I had a kid who told me that I was wrong, which that's fine. And this was on a different subject, but he said that he read that marijuana is actually really, really positive and a good thing for teens to sleep and use and relaxation. I said, oh, really, where'd you get that? And he said, Don, you were wrong about this. I said, okay, where'd you get it? And he shows me the website.
结果是 www.cannabis.org。好吧，我不得不向他解释，他们可能会有自己的动机。完全正确，对吧？所以，学会如何辨别你获取新闻的渠道，这是一个巨大、巨大的挑战。那么，布劳尔博士，我在引言中提到，你也研究偏见、歧视，以及属于高权力和低权力群体的后果。我相信你现在正在做一些工作，研究媒体对偏见和歧视故事的持续曝光将如何影响边缘化群体的成员。你能谈谈这方面的内容以及你的发现吗？当然。我和我的研究生南希·艾森伯格（Naomi Eisenberg）目前正在开展一个研究项目，我们一次又一次地发现，人们实际上低估了同龄人对多元化的承诺、对包容性的承诺，以及同龄人对诸如组织内支持多元化举措的支持。这会产生非常重要的后果，因为人们相信，实际上他们的大多数同龄人都并不在乎多元化，不在乎包容性。这反过来又影响了他们自己的行为。
Well, it was www.cannabis.org. Well, I had to explain, they might have a reason for that. Exactly. Right, right. So learning how to be discriminating about where you get your news, that's a big, big challenge. So, Dr. Brower, I mentioned in the introduction that you also study prejudice, discrimination, and the consequences of belonging to high and low-powered groups. And you're doing some work now, I believe that looking at how constant media exposure to stories about prejudice and discrimination may affect members of marginalized groups. Can you talk about that and what you're finding? Sure. Together with my graduate student, Naomi Eisenberg, we are currently working on a research project, and we're finding over and over again that people actually underestimate their peers, commitment to diversity, commitment to inclusion, and their peers support for, let's say, their organizations, pro-diversity initiatives. And that has very important consequences because what people believe is that actually that most of their peers are sort of don't care about diversity, don't care about inclusion. And that then influences their own behavior.
一方面，这导致他们不愿与同龄人谈论这些问题。如果你觉得多元化对你的同龄人来说不是一个有趣的话题，你为什么还要和他们谈论呢？这也围绕着不采取行动、不做任何改变创造了一种社会规范。所以，我不知道。我们对美国公民的代表性样本进行了一项研究。我认为90%的人表示种族多元化对国家有利。我们有超过，我认为50%或60%的人支持“黑人的命也是命”运动。许多许多人表示，他们非常乐意看到自己的地方税收用于学校的项目，
It actually on the one hand, it causes them to not talk about these issues with their peers. Why would you talk to your peers if you sort of think that that's not a topic that is interesting for your peers? And it also creates sort of social norms around not taking action and not doing anything about it. So I don't know. We conducted a study with a representative sample of U.S. citizens. I think 90% of the people said that racial diversity benefits the country. We have more than, I think, 50 or 60% who support the Black Lives Matter movement. many, many people state that they're very happy with their local taxes going to programs for schools,
帮助来自边缘化背景的孩子在学校取得成功。许多人说，是的，我同意将我的州税在一定程度上用于为上大学的边缘化群体学生提供奖学金。因此，我们所拥有的是，实际上大多数人关心多元化，希望社会变革，并且意识到系统性不公的形式。但他们同时也相信自己是唯一这样想的人。他们相信大多数其他人并不关心这些问题，甚至多少持有消极态度等等。
helping children from marginalized backgrounds succeed in schools. Many of them say, yes, I'm fine with my state taxes being devoted to some extent for scholarships for students from marginalized groups who go to college. So what we have is we actually have a majority of people who care about diversity and who want social change, who are aware of systemic forms of injustice. But they also believe that they are the only ones. They believe that the majority of other people don't care about these issues and even or slightly have negative attitudes or whatever.
这不仅对政策，而且对人际行为都产生了重要影响。我们正在努力寻找各种解决这个问题的方法，我们提出了一系列干预措施，实际上纠正了这些误解，这似乎确实产生了一系列重要的下游后果，从人们表现得更具包容性，到更愿意代表多元化和包容性采取行动。这是一个非常令人兴奋的项目，因为我认为它再次展示了媒体的影响力，以及这如何对人们的行为产生真正的影响。在这个案例中，主题是多元化、公平和包容。
And that has important consequences both for policy but also for interpersonal behavior. And we're trying to think about a variety of ways how to fix that. and we came up with a number of interventions where we actually correct these misperceptions, and it does seem to have a number of important downstream consequences from people behaving more inclusively, more willing to take action on behalf of diversity and inclusion. And that is a very exciting project because I think it shows once again the media influence and how that has real effects of people's behavior. And in this case, it's diversity, equity, and inclusion.
我想花几分钟时间谈谈我在引言中提到的那些算法，无论我们是否愿意，它们都在向我们推送各种各样乱七八糟的东西。新闻消费者有什么办法可以保护自己吗？使用无痕浏览会有帮助吗？有些浏览器声称它们能保护你的隐私，这是获取新闻并阻止算法继续向你发送相同故事的更好方法吗？我的意思是，信息流是无休止的。格兰特博士，你考虑过这个问题，研究过吗？在日常生活中，我们来谈谈社交媒体。你点击某事物的次数越多，哪怕它是负面的，它给你的喂食就越多。
I wanted to talk for a couple of minutes about the algorithms that I mentioned in the intro that are pushing all kinds of stuff to us, whether we want it or not. Is there anything consumers of news can do to protect themselves? Would it help to browse incognito? Are there some browsers that they claim that they'll protect your privacy? Is that a better way to get your news and maybe to stop the algorithms to keep sending you the same stories and just, I mean, the feeds are endless. Dr. Grant, have you thought about this, looked at that? On a daily basis, let's talk about social media. The more you click on something, even if it's negative, the more it's going to feed you.
算法确实是这样运作的，无论是联系人还是你关注的人。负面新闻，它就会给你越来越多这样的内容。所以在如何控制它方面，好吧，我告诉家长、孩子和我自己的孩子的一件事是，我知道这很麻烦。我知道这需要多花一点时间，但通常只要你点击某事，就会弹出一个窗口，上面写着“Cookie和设置”。所以，我住在加利福尼亚州，所以我们这里有一条非常酷的法律，他们不能出售他们的用户信息等等。但我教导这一点是因为进入某些平台或新平台去更改设置非常重要。这样它就不会做广告。你可以控制所有这一切。我还强烈建议
The algorithms do work that way, whether it's a contact or someone who you follow. negative news, it is going to give you more and more of that. So in terms of how you control it, well, one of the things I tell parents and kids and my own children is I know that it's a hassle. I know it takes a more another moment, but very often whenever you click on something, it will come up with a pop-up window that says cookies and settings. So, and I live in California, so we have a very cool kind of law here that they cannot sell their information and all of that. But I teach this because it's important to go in for certain platforms or new platforms to go in and change the settings. So it does not do advertising. You can control all of this. I also really encourage
关闭警报，关闭通知，因为当你听到警报声响起时，根据具体内容，你会获得一点多巴胺或皮质醇的刺激，然后你看着它，接着你就陷入了数字漩涡，因为点击诱饵会把你套牢。而他们的目标就是抓住你。有趣的是，设计师、开发人员——我都和这些人交谈过——他们对此直言不讳。他们的目标就是把你留在平台上，或者像赌场一样把你弄进去并让你留在那里。他们使用的是……你知道的，可变奖励，这和老虎机使用的是同一套东西。他们利用了我们大脑中的一个小缺陷，让我们总是不断回头。我们不知道会得到什么。如果你
turn off the alerts, turn off the notifications because that little dopamine or cortisol hit that you get depending on what it is, when you hear that alert, go off and then it feeds and then you look at it, then you're down the digital vortex because the clickbait's going to get you. And their goal is to get you. And it's interesting because designers, developers, I've talked to these people, they talk about it openly. Their goal is to get you on the platform or get you in there like a casino and keep you there. And they're used, you know, the variable rewards, the same thing is used in slot machines. They leverage a little flaw in our brains that we will always keep going back. We don't know what we're going to get. And if you
想想老虎机，你看着它，这一切都与边缘系统有关，但可变奖励机制就是老虎机。你会坐在那里，拉动那个把手。拉动那个把手。拉动那个把手。嗯，我曾交谈过——因为我……你必须钦佩这种舞台管理，我想这就是他们的工作。但当他们最初想出如何复制这一点并击中那个小弱点时，那就是滑动。这是相同的动作。是相同的。他们无法在设备上安装一个杠杆。
think about a slot machine and you look and this is all tied to the Olympic system, but variable rewards is the slot machine. You'll sit there and you'll pull that arm. You'll pull that arm. You'll pull that arm. Well, and I've talked because I've, you got to admire the stage management of this because I guess this was their job. But when they first came up with how to, to replicate that and hit that little vulnerability, It's the swipe. It's the same action. It's the same. They can't put a lever on a device.
但他们能做出的、具有相同躯体和心理反应的最接近的东西就是滑动。因为你永远不知道会得到什么。你永远不知道会得到什么。你永远不知道会得到什么。这就是老虎机的心态。然后七个小时就这样过去了。因此，请记住——我认为对父母、教育工作者、临床医生和我们所有人都很重要的一点是——教育大家这一切是如何运作的，不仅仅是算法，再次强调，取决于你使用的是哪个
But the closest they could come to that has the same somatic and psychological and response is the swipe. Because you never know what you're going to get. You never know what you're going to get. You never know what you're going to get. It's the slot machine mentality. And then seven hours have gone by. So keeping in mind, and I think it's important for parents and educators and clinicians and all of us to educate how this all works, not just the algorithms, which again, depending on which
平台，他们都在说：“哦，是的，我们已经走在前头了，我们在保护，我们在做那件事”，但你应该知道它是如何运作的。作为一个数字移民（就像我一样），我可能更难理解这一点。而我的孩子们，他们懂。这是他们日常词汇的一部分。他们直接忽略它。但我们要去教育并让所有人都知道：好吧，有哪些东西在被用来获取我们的信任、并诱骗我们留在被称为数字世界的赌场里？了解他们是如何做出的这一切，然后我们才能做出明智的决定。因为当我们谈论不同种类的媒体饱和过载时，另一个问题是，当我们被如此之多的信息或关于同一主题或同一故事的如此多的报道所猛烈轰炸时，
platform you talk to, they're all saying, oh yeah, we got ahead of this, we're protecting, we're doing that, but you should know how it works. Understand, as digital immigrants as I am, it's a little harder for me to grasp. My kids, like, they know this. This is part of their nomenclature. They just ignore it. But educating and all of us knowing, okay, so what are the things are using to get us and trick us to keep us in the casino called the digital, whatever it is, knowing how they do that, and then we can make an informed decision because when we were talking about the different kinds of media saturation overload, the other problem is that when we are so blitzkrieged with so much information or so many stories on the same topic or the same story,
研究证明，当你接收到如此饱和的故事，并且无法真正消化它们时，要对那个主题的想法做出明智的决定是非常困难的。信息量太大了。我不知道布劳尔博士是否同意这一点，但……我只是抛出这个想法。我完全同意。我认为人们对社交媒体平台的目标没有足够的认识。它们的目标是让用户再次返回。这与
studies have evidence that it's very difficult to make an informed decision about your thoughts, about that topic when you're getting so much saturation of stories about it, and you can't really process it. It's too much. And I don't know if Dr. Brer would agree with that, but, you know, just throwing it out there. I agree entirely. I think people are not sufficiently aware of the goal, of the story. social media platforms. The goal is to make users come back. It doesn't have anything to do with
信息没有任何关系。它们不想，我不知道，让人们感觉良好。它们的目标是让用户回来。这与广告挂钩。所以这与收入挂钩。这就是这些算法的目标，对吧？对的，因为我们就是产品。哦，天哪。金，我一直这么说。哦，天哪，我说，如果它是免费的，那你就是产品。所以，你知道，目前对于“新闻过载”并没有正式的诊断，但鉴于人们的表现确实与成瘾相似，正如你所描述的那样，格兰特博士，这类似于成瘾。我们是否应该将其视为一种成瘾形式，并探讨将其视为一种综合征（如果不是一种诊断的话）的可能性？好吧，在当前的《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》（DSM）中，目前处于“进一步研究的病症”中的有网络游戏障碍。这是一个切入点。我很幸运。我有幸参与了一篇针对该议题撰写的论文，作者包括我的同事道格·詹蒂莱（Doug Gentile）等人。为了保持透明，我就是那个“等人”之一。我们对此做出了回应，并期待在小修订版的DSM（即5.5版）中加入它。但它没有被收录进去。不过我们希望在第六版中，我预测它会被命名为类似于“游戏障碍”的名称。我们
information. They don't want to, I don't know, make people feel good. The goal is to make users come back. And then that's tied to advertisements. So that's tied to income. So that is the goal of these algorithms, right? Right. Because we are the product. Oh, my goodness. Kim, I say this all the time. Oh my goodness, I say, if it's free, you're the product. So, you know, there's no formal diagnosis of news overload, but given that people do behave in ways that are similar, as you described, similar, Dr. Grant, to being addicted. Should we be looking at this as a form of addiction
希望它能成功入选。
and maybe exploring the idea of a syndrome, if not a diagnosis? Okay, so in the current DSM, right now, conditions for further study is online gaming disorder. It's a foothold. And I'm very fortunate. And I got to be a part of a paper that was written in response to that with some of my colleagues, Doug Gentile et al. I'm one of the at all, just to be transparent. We responded to that and we're looking for the little mid-DSM, the 5.5. And it didn't get in that. But we're hoping that in the six, I predict it's going to be called something like gaming disorder. And we're, We're hoping it makes it.
但我们还没到第六版，我们也知道这需要多长时间。所以当我们看到6.5版或第7版时，也许吧，我一直在密切关注这一点，因为世界其他地方和世界卫生组织已经对它进行了分类。当我们查看拟议的标准并列出一堆标准时，我们心里很诚实地想，你知道的，等这件事真正发生时，地球上的每个人可能都会符合至少六到八个标准。因此，要去预测它真正会变成什么样，其实更多会关于情绪失调、任何生物学层面的问题——我知道布劳尔博士比我更能谈论这一点——
But we're not even at the six yet, and we know how long this takes. So when we're looking at the 6.5 or the 7, maybe, I'm watching this closely because the rest of the world and the World Health Organization has classified it. When we looked at the proposed criteria and just listed a bunch of them, we thought to ourselves, very honestly, you know, by the time this thing happens, probably everyone on the planet will hit at least six or eight of the criteria. for what this is. So try to prognosticate what it would really be more about the emotional dysregulation, about any biological, and I know Dr. Brower can speak about this better than me,
任何生物学、心理学层面的问题，因为当我审视客户、孩子、成年人、患者或无论你想怎么称呼他们身上的任何问题时，我都会看它产生了什么影响。当你谈论某种东西是成瘾还是依赖时。我是这样看的，也正是这样做的：我首先进行观察并诚实地交谈，我们去经历并试图确定：这种行为是否在负面地冲击或影响生物学、心理学、社会学、学业/职业（取决于他们的年龄）或者你健康的内环境稳态？我们审视它是否触及了其中任何一个方面。如果你在所有这些维度中审视设备的使用，你就会看到成年人也是如此，它如何
any biological, psychological, psychological, because when I look at anything with a client or a kid or adult or a patient or whatever you want to call them, I look at how does it impact? Like when you talk about it is something an addiction or dependency. What I go through, and I do it in this way, I first look and I talk honestly, we go through and we try to identify, is this behavior negatively impacting or influencing biological, psychological, sociological, academic slash career, depending on their age or environmental of your health and of your homeostasis? We look at, is it hitting any of those? If you look at device use in all of those silos, you see how an adult's as well, how it
在负面地影响、左右、阻碍、干预这些方面。那么，面对这种情况你该怎么办呢？好吧，我不知道。其他人可能会有不同的看法。我认为，如果你在使用设备、进行各种搜索或出于任何动机时不能做到进出自如，如果你在10分钟内没有出来，你在里面干什么？在10分钟或15分钟后，他们发现转折点就发生了，特别是——我主要是指社交媒体。当有人发布了某些内容时——我经常谈论这一点，因为我经常谈论社交媒体——太棒了，我喜欢能够看到我的朋友和家人。
is negatively impacting, influencing, impeding, intervening on that. So in terms of what do you do about it? Well, I don't know. Other people may have other opinions. I think that if you're not in and out of your device and whatever thing you're searching for or whatever your motivation, if you're not out in about 10 minutes, what do you do in there? After 10 minutes or 15 minutes, what they're seeing is that's when the inflection point happens. especially, and I'm talking really in terms of social media. And when someone posts something, and I talk about this a lot, because I talk a lot about social media, great, I love being able to see my friends, my family.
正在对此产生负面影响、干扰、阻碍或干涉。那么，关于该如何应对呢？嗯，我不知道。其他人可能有不同的看法。我认为，如果你没有在十分钟内进出你的设备以及无论你在搜索什么东西或无论你的动机是什么，如果你没有在大约十分钟内出来，你在里面做什么呢？在十分钟或十五分钟之后，他们看到的是，拐点就在那时发生。特别是，我主要指的是社交媒体。当有人发帖时，我经常谈论这个，因为我经常谈论社交媒体，太好了，我喜欢能够看到我的朋友、我的家人。
I was just at my niece's wedding back east. I don't live back east. I knew my family's lives that I don't get to talk to. But what I talk about, and I say this three times in every presentation I do, and I always have, if you are posting anything on social media, and I don't care, what is your real motivation? because my close friends in my closest orbit know what's going on. They knew I was at that wedding. So I don't care why, but if you're posting or you're trying to be a voyeur
我刚刚在东部参加了侄女的婚礼。我不住在东部。我知道那些我平时联系不上的家人的生活。但我想说的是，我在每个演讲中都会说三次，而且我一直都这么做：如果你在社交媒体上发布任何内容，我不在乎，你的真正动机是什么？因为我最核心圈子的好朋友都知道发生了什么。他们知道我去了那场婚礼。所以我不在乎原因是什么，但如果你在发布内容，或者你想当一个偷窥狂
or whatever your behavior is on social media, but if you're posting, what is your motivation? What do you need? Everyone outside that inner circle who probably knows what's going on in your life, let's talk about what you really need and why you need the whole digiverse to know or whatever you're posting up there. Why is that important information for you to share? And it's different.
或者无论你在社交媒体上的行为是什么，但如果你在发帖，你的动机是什么？你需要什么？核心圈子之外的每个人可能都知道你生活里发生了什么，我们来谈谈你真正需要什么，以及为什么你需要整个数字宇宙都知道或者无论你在上面发了什么。为什么那是你需要分享的重要信息？这其实是不一样的。
So that's also why I'm questioning. Like, why are you on social media? And I'll end with this, because I just did a presentation on bullying, and my part was cyberbullying. We were talking about just being in the vortex. I was shocked because I would have gotten this wrong. Family feud question, what platform has the most prevalence of cyberbullying? and I would have been wrong.
这也是为什么我在质疑。比如，你为什么要在社交媒体上？我就以这个结束，因为我刚做了一个关于霸凌的演讲，我的部分是网络霸凌。我们当时在讨论那种深陷漩涡的感觉。我很震惊，因为我本来会猜错的。这是一个家庭问答秀的问题：哪个平台网络霸凌最普遍？而我之前会猜错。
It's YouTube. And I work with, because what happens is creators put things up there, and then people respond and come at them. And so I, when we were talking about being lost in the vortex, I can't even tell you how many times I've sat with a client who has, their sleep hygiene has been disrupted by YouTube. They've been up all night. And I asked them, quite frankly, okay, can you tell me,
是YouTube。我合作的对象，因为发生的情况是创作者把内容放到网上，然后人们就会反击和攻击他们。所以当我，当我们谈到迷失在漩涡中时，我甚至无法告诉你我有多少次和客户坐在一起，他们的睡眠卫生被YouTube打乱了。他们整晚不睡觉。我开门见山地问他们，好吧，你能告诉我，
one video, what did you see? It is shocking to be the phenomenon to a one. They can't remember one video and they were up all night. So when you talk about how it impacts those different silos, and again, Dr. Brewer can speak to this much better than me. I just have kitchen table experience of dealing with kids and family for 20 years and through this whole rise of the Internet and all the digital, the portable digital use, but that's what I got.
一个视频，你看到了什么？这种现象简直令人震惊，无一例外。他们记不清一个视频，但他们却熬了一整夜。所以，当你谈到它如何影响这些不同的领域时，再次说明，布劳尔博士能比我更好地谈论这一点。我只有20年来处理孩子和家庭问题的“厨房餐桌”经验，并经历了互联网和所有数字产品、便携式数字设备的兴起，这就是我的经验。
I don't know. Dr. Brower, what's your opinion here? do you agree? And do we need to have something in the DSM that really flags this as a serious, serious problem? I'm actually interested in what, because I respect, what you would call it. I have no idea, media addiction or some syndrome, but it's going to be tough to do that, partly because it's correlated with so many other things and all the causal directions go in all, all the causal effects go in all directions. So on the one hand, we know, that social media consumption leads to poor mental health, right? Everybody else seems to be having
我不知道。布劳尔博士，你在这里有什么看法？你同意吗？我们是否需要在《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》（DSM）中加入一些真正将其标记为严重、严重问题的条目？我其实对你如何称呼它很感兴趣，因为我很尊重你的专业意见。我不知道，这叫媒体 addiction（媒体成瘾）还是某种综合征，但这很难做到，部分原因在于它与其他许多事情相关联，而且所有的因果方向都指向各个方向，所有的因果效应都是全方位的。一方面，我们知道，社交媒体的使用会导致糟糕的心理健康，对吧？每个人看起来都在过得
fun. Everybody else is on these great vacations and I'm not. Terrible fear of missing out. So I'm sorry to interrupt you. I call that compare and despair. Compare and despair. So it leads to poor mental health, but also sometimes social media use are indicators of other clinical problems, right? Loneliness, social awkwardness, inability to connect. No close social support network, etc. So the correlations and relationships with other clinical issues are close, and it's going to be hard to distinguish it from that. So I want to move to something slightly different. Yes, maybe we need a clinical diagnosis, but we could also sort of in the meantime work on making things better.
很开心。其他人都在度过精彩的假期，而我没有。可怕的“错失恐惧症”（FOMO）。不好意思打断你。我把这叫做“比较与绝望”。比较与绝望。所以它会导致糟糕的心理健康，但有时社交媒体的使用也是其他临床问题的指标，对吧？孤独、社交笨拙、无力连接。没有紧密的社会支持网络等等。因此，它与其他临床问题的相关性和关系很紧密，很难将它与这些问题区分开来。所以我想转到一个稍微不同的问题。是的，也许我们需要一个临床诊断，但与此同时，我们也可以努力把事情做得更好。
I think much of it is raising awareness in the public or maybe among our teenagers. So we already talked about how hardwired we are for negative events. We just talked about how these social media platforms feed us information that is negative and that make us come back and what their ultimate goal is. I think also it should be made quite clear that people are very bad at distinguishing distinguishing real news from fake news. And people widely exaggerate, overestimate their ability to do that. We're actually incredibly poor.
我认为很大程度上是在公众中或也许在青少年中提高意识。我们之前已经讨论过我们对负面事件是多么地“硬编码”。我们刚刚讨论了这些社交媒体平台如何向我们输送负面信息，让我们不断回访，以及它们的最终目标是什么。我认为还应该非常明确地指出，人们很难区分真实新闻和虚假新闻。人们极大地夸大、高估了自己这方面的能力。实际上我们差得难以置信。
And there are hundreds of studies showing exactly that, that what is on there. And even if it's a little video and even if it's people with a white coat standing on the stairs of the Capitol, that does not mean that that is actually official information and has any value. So we are very bad at judging, distinguishing fake news from real news. And finally, I think what we need is a little bit more training, maybe statistical thinking or being able to understand uncertainty. And what it means, like to come back to the study was the initial weeks of COVID-19.
有数百项研究恰好证明了这一点，证明了上面有什么。即使是一个小视频，即使是穿着白大褂的人站在国会山的台阶上，这也不意味着那是官方信息并且具有任何价值。因此我们非常不善于判断、区分虚假新闻和真实新闻。最后，我认为我们需要的是更多一点的训练，也许是统计思维，或者是理解不确定性的能力。这意味着什么，比如回到COVID-19最初几周的研究。
We didn't really know what was going on. But certain pieces of information were more reliable than other. others and we knew more about that. So at this stage, we now think it might be airborne. Okay, that is an uncertain judgment. And then now it's 99% sure that it's airborne and that actually that's how its transmission works and we can stop disinfecting our groceries. Teaching people to sort of read through the lines and what is reliable information
我们并不是真的很清楚发生了什么。但某些信息比其他信息更可靠，而且我们对那些信息了解得更多。所以在现阶段，我们现在认为它可能是空气传播的。好吧，这是一个不确定的判断。然后现在有99%的把握确定它是通过空气传播的，而且这确实是它的传播方式，我们可以停止给杂货消毒了。教导人们如何字里行间地阅读，什么是可靠信息
and what is unreliable information. And then maybe the next step is where do you get that information? Maybe social media is not the right place to get that information. Maybe you should be going on the web site if you really want to know about affection risk. And what we currently know, maybe the CDC website is the better. Or every state has a health department. And they're now making a real effort to provide information for non-experts, non-scientists, sometimes even for kids, adolescents.
什么是不可靠信息。然后也许下一步就是你从哪里获取这些信息？也许社交媒体并不是获取这些信息的正确地方。如果你真的想知道感染风险以及我们目前所知，也许你应该去访问网站，CDC（疾病控制与预防中心）的网站可能是更好的选择。或者每个州都有卫生部门。他们现在正在真诚地努力为非专家、非科学家，有时甚至为儿童、青少年提供信息。
So I think maybe we should teach our, especially our teenagers and friends, we go to different sources for different things. I think we go to social media to watch cute animal videos and they make us feel good. And then that's okay. And then if we want to know what the infection risk is and how I can minimize that and actually whether I should go to my grandfather's 85th birthday in the time of COVID, I think the CDC website might be the better source than social media. I agree with that. You know, I teach healthy device management in the practice of good digital citizenship. If you look at the reason
所以我认为也许我们应该教导我们的，尤其是我们的青少年和朋友们，针对不同的事情我们要去不同的渠道。我认为我们去社交媒体是为了看可爱的动物视频，它们让我们感觉良好。那没关系。然后如果我们想知道感染风险是什么以及我如何将其降到最低，以及在新冠时期我到底该不该去参加我祖父的85岁生日，我认为CDC网站可能比社交媒体是更好的信息源。我同意这一点。你知道，我在实践中教授健康的设备管理和良好的数字公民素养。如果你看看原因
why ostensibly we even seek out news sources, it's to get information that we don't have or we don't know and to learn. As humans, I fear that what I'm seeing and what I believe in our psychology and our fear-based belief system, we tend to believe people who say things that align with what we feel. We're not really as interested in learning from the other side. So right now, you can find anything, something that aligns with your belief system,
为什么表面上我们甚至去寻找新闻来源，是为了获得我们没有或不知道的信息并进行学习。作为人类，我担心我所看到的以及我相信的我们的心理学和基于恐惧的信念系统，我们倾向于相信那些说的话符合我们感受的人。我们其实对从另一方那里学习不那么感兴趣。所以现在，你可以找到任何东西，找到符合你信念系统的东西，
whether it's whatever, but you can find people, and I love that Dr. Barr said, the white coat. Anyone can put on a white coat. and we're used to believing what they say. But I think that we are so used to, we will follow, and I mean that in both ways, both in terms of the definition that it was traditional
无论是什什么，但你能找到人，我很高兴巴尔博士（注：口误应为布劳尔博士）说到了白大褂。任何人都可以穿上白大褂，而我们习惯于相信他们所说的话。但我认为我们太习惯于，我们会追随，我指的是两种意义上的追随，既指它是传统的定义，
and also now with social media, we'll follow people who kind of say things that make sense and aligns with our beliefs. I don't know if we're really interested in learning new things. And the idea that we then can share that, with others and it can just grow and grow and grow and grow and then had a groundswell of suddenly you have these cabals of people sharing misinformation. This is something, again, that's new. And what Dr. Brower said is something I'm very interested in I'm doing right now. Critical thinking.
也指现在有了社交媒体，我们会追随那些说的话听起来有道理并符合我们信念的人。我不知道我们是否真的对学习新东西感兴趣。然后这种想法我们可以与他人分享，它可以不断地增长、增长、增长、增长，然后形成了一股气势，突然间你就有了一群传播虚假信息的人。这也是一个新现象。布劳尔博士所说的是我非常感兴趣并且正在做的事情：批判性思维。
Critical thinking is something that we are very trained to do. I remember my mentor explaining me when I first was going and pursuing this that Wikipedia is not a citable source. I didn't know. So critical thinking, and I think it's very important that we have policies, just like everything we've added in, just like what's going on now with inclusion and diversity, as we grow and evolve and become more sentient and kinder and more open-minded, I think that it is vital that we do not avoid this and that in the curriculum, starting young, before they even get on devices, I think that critical thinking and device, healthy device management, And good digital citizenship, I think these should be deregure protocol curriculum pieces
批判性思维是我们经过大量训练才能做到的事情。我记得我的导师在我最初开始从事并追求这个领域时向我解释，维基百科不是一个可引用的来源。我当时并不知道。所以批判性思维，我认为制定政策非常重要，就像我们加入的所有其他事情一样，就像现在关于包容性和多样性的事情一样，随着我们成长、进化、变得更有同理心、更善良、思想更开放，我认为至关重要的一点是，我们不能回避这一点，并且在课程中，从娃娃抓起，在他们接触电子设备之前，我认为批判性思维和健康的设备管理，以及良好的数字公民素养，我认为这些应该成为常规协议课程的一部分
because we need to get ahead of it before the kids actually get on the device. And I tell parents, you know, whatever, and I talk about good digital citizenship. And this is, again, with cyberbullying and other trolling things that we've now seen. I tell parents, here's the basic thing that I suggest. Before you let your children have that privilege of that device which you're paying for, sit down with them and discuss what are your family values. of how you treat people, IRL in real life, and that absolutely is the expectation of how it should translate online. But I think that if we don't put this kind of curriculum and educate kids and the
因为我们需要在孩子们真正接触设备之前走在前面。我告诉家长们，无论如何，我都在谈论良好的数字公民素养。这再次关系到我们现在看到的网络霸凌和其他骂战。我告诉家长，这是我建议的基本事项：在你允许你的孩子拥有你付费购买的那个设备特权之前，和他们坐下来，讨论你们的家庭价值观是什么，即你在现实生活中（IRL）如何对待他人，这绝对是在线交流中应该贯彻的期望。但我认为，如果我们不设立这种课程并教育孩子、
community and parents and what we're doing right now, this is the good use of all this digital media, your show, Kim, this can reach people. I don't know who's going to be listening to this, but maybe they heard something, but I think that this should be deregur protocol of critical thinking, discerning information, where to find sources that are, you know, that are trusted. And this should be a part of school curriculum because this is a part of our kids everyday life. Once we go into virtual reality, augmented reality, mix or whatever, AI, whatever's coming, why don't we have this in the schools? Because they're going to use this probably more than calculus, the kids, because now they don't
社区、家长以及我们现在正在做的事情，这是所有这些数字媒体的良好用途，你的节目，金，这可以触达人们。我不知道谁会听这个，但也许他们听到了一些东西，但我认为这应该成为批判性思维、辨别信息、在哪里寻找可信来源的常规协议。这应该成为学校课程的一部分，因为这是我们孩子日常生活的一部分。一旦我们进入虚拟现实、增强现实、混合现实或者其他什么，人工智能，无论接下来会发生什么，为什么我们的学校里没有这些？因为孩子们以后使用这些东西的频率可能会超过微积分，因为现在他们
need calculus because they can just ask Surrey to solve the problem for them. Well, I'm going to have to thank you both. I think this is fascinating and we could probably go on for another hour and still have new things to say because this is such a hot area. But I want to thank you both for joining me today. Well, thank you. Thank you so much, Kim. For our listeners who want to learn more about media overload and psychology's reaction to it, please see the November, December, issue of APA's magazine, The Monitor, which is on our website at www.ap.org slash monitor. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.w.
不再需要微积分了，因为他们可以直接让Siri帮他们解决问题。好吧，我得谢谢你们两位。我认为这太迷人了，我们可能可以再聊一个小时，却依然有新话题可谈，因为这是一个如此热门的领域。但我要感谢你们两位今天能来参加。好的，谢谢。非常感谢，金。对于想要更多了解媒体过载以及心理学对此反应的听众，请参阅APA杂志《监视器》（The Monitor）11月/12月刊，它在我们网站 www.apa.org/monitor 上。您可以在我们的网站 www.w. 上找到往期的《心理学访谈》（Speaking of Psychology）节目
Speakingof Psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you're hearing, please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyenne. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
SpeakingofPsychology.org，或者在Apple、Stitcher或您获取播客的任何地方收听。如果您喜欢我们的节目，请给我们留个评论。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学访谈》由莉·温纳曼（Lee Winerman）制作。我们的音频剪辑师是克里斯·孔迪安（Chris Condyenne）。感谢收听美国心理学会的节目。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。本集节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。